foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
what would you do with this assignment
of defense was transferred to you
[Applause]
I promise you probably had successes
everyone
around
[Music]
this is my uniform
I love the French Victory too long
what is your name Napoleon
that's the course of my life just
changed Napoleon
I'm destined for greatness
for those in power will only see me as a
sword
I suggest you take the throne as a king
shall we vote
[Applause]
[Music]
this learning has held the world of
Hostage with his egotism and his lack of
simple good manners
Old Europe is United forces against me
what's the outcome of this if you don't
succeed
Your Majesty we are discovered good
first to admit when I make a mistake
I simply never do
[Music]
kill Denver's prodigal child of the
Milky Way
Nick Fury my favorite one-eyed man of
intrigue how goes it out there I don't
know cold No Air
space
[Applause]
Captain Marvel be Annihilator
you took everything from me
and now I'm returning the favor
what is happening to me
she's entangled our light-based powers
so we switch places whenever we use them
strong Theory
you can absorb light
I can see it and Kamala who's Kamala hi
she can turn light into physical matter
which I have never heard of I could
totally show you no
[Music]
what
profile
[Music]
he's targeting every planet we call home
I would never choose to bring anybody
into this
you are not the only thing standing
between this and the universe
[Music]
faster
I can't can you I got it
Sing My Race
car
[Applause]
[Music]
oh crap
listen son you think you're gonna play a
stupid video game about cars and you're
gonna become a Race Car Driver
all I ever wanted to do is be a racer
I'm doing it
the 10 of you are the best
Grand tourism
your chance to race real cars it's not
gonna work the guys who race are Elite
athletes your kids are scrawny little
gamer kids that's where you come in
hmm
do you think you can do the impossible
I'm here to prove that you can't
beat
you get puked on my lawn I know what I'm
doing not afraid I've raced this track a
thousand times in a game let me drive it
my way
that was actually pretty great
we have a newcomer this year and his
presence is shaking the foundation of
the sport this is the major leagues the
other drivers your pit crew are going to
hate you much easier with the joystick
isn't it
I can't see anything
I'm not sure if I can do this most
people can't I got a feeling you're not
most people
if I lose
others more than just the race
so I'm not gonna quit I'm gonna prove to
everyone
don't you belong
you've raised it what like a thousand
times now you've just gotta do it in
real life
Gran Turismo based on a true story
I've spent the past seven years
traveling the world perfecting my craft
you see I'm something of a magician
inventor and chocolate maker so quiet up
and listen down nope scratch that
reverse it
Mr Wonka Rock and say you're a man a
great Ingenuity what are you doing I'm
making chocolate of course how do you
like it dark white nutty absolutely
insane many people have come here to
sell chocolate they've all been crushed
by the chocolate cartel you can't get a
shock without selling chocolate and you
can't sell chocolate without a shop
no daydreaming what are we gonna do
Willie
huh huh
huh a double heart take a pencil paper
uh-huh I got an idea
I know things haven't been easy for you
they're gonna get better you promise I
think he promised left the most solemn
bow there is where do we start
where is this it's just cool what's
happening
let's find out shall we who's forever
job
nothing to see here just a small group
of people to find the laws of gravity
ladies and gentlemen that's the gallery
Gourmet
my name is Willy Wonka
oh he's good too good
pretty sure I've gained about 150 pounds
in the last two weeks you could change
her life as organ change all their lives
every good thing in this world started
with a dream
[Music]
mark my words this is gonna be the
greatest chocolate shop
the world has ever seen
so you're the funny little man who's
been following me I will have you know
that I am a perfectly respectable size
foreign
something doesn't feel right
so if you what happened
there's something here
that's not meant to be
[Applause]
nice
what's she doing
she's standing there
this thing it's come back for me
this demon was once an angel
rejected by God
stripped of power
it wants that power back
it's okay to be scared I'm scared too
you send that thing back to hell
[Music]
thank you
I want to fly ah let's do this
[Music]
yeah
you gotta force it to come out what are
you you're a genius I know like what'd I
say
oh did you know what was gonna happen to
my brother when you stuck him with this
world destroying thing
it's called the Scarab
I had no idea it would activate it has
to choose you
so how do we get into untrust me
[Music]
post acquired who said that distance
threat eliminated
still awake
do you think the government is gonna do
when they figure out that some kid has
this military attack
the world with the power of the Scarab
it belongs to me
but I swear
the world is a place to protect I have
an Arsenal at my disposal
whatever you can imagine
I can create yeah that's more like it
below you feel for your family makes you
weak you're wrong my family that's what
makes me strong
oh I forgot how bad it looks
you're the Blue Beetle if I could use
that Arsenal right about now I can never
ask oh yeah
Bust It Down bust it down
I advise me back away
[Music]
[Applause]
isn't it beautiful this is awesome maybe
we should go say hi hey there Jack
talked to a girl a girl he wants to
marry her what I say that you said it
with your eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
they must be migrating migration what a
stupid idea okay you're impossible
because I found a safe place for us to
live
I want us to get out and see the world
what sort of father would I be if I put
my young child In Harm's Way for no
reason except the chance at a Caribbean
vacation I don't want to miss out in
life because you're afraid to leave this
pond
thank you
hey
why are we the only Birds heading this
way
what is this place
I promise adventure and this is exactly
what I promised
on top
can we land you're old enough to do it
in the sky now we have a number two
situation oh but it's gross every bird
does it in the sky
no one there I told you we are not
Landing there is no way we're Landing
when Mallard do it now or we leave
without you okay okay
we are completely lost we're trying to
get to Jamaica that I love birds it's
this way well we are not flying through
this crazy death trap of a city just
stay close to me and everything will be
all right
I'm okay yeah no I'm okay we can do this
maybe you don't stick too close
I am Dr nandor fodorp the world's
foremost parapsychologist I am not a
skeptic this is the strangest case I
have ever enthalated a family living in
a farmhouse claim a talking Mongoose
lives in their Barn creature's name is
Jeff
what do you think about it
a talking Mongoose
Did You observe this creature no no I
did hear it we are going to the Isle of
Man I have almost 20 years of research
in this field
in order to see Jeff is the creature
here well because we can't see him
doesn't mean he ain't here I see
the daughter is
a tremendous skepticism in
this is an inexplicable Force
you say the way Rascal is probably
watching us right now everybody on this
island has their Jeff story tell me
yours you and I both know there ain't no
job
[Music]
can you tell him to come out so he can
see him
is that him there
strike me as con artists
we're here with our eyes as much as we
do Aries these people are lying I think
he exists I'm certain of it
just show yourself I mean you know harm
please
yes just show me that you're real
hello
[Music]
foreign
years ago today the artificial
intelligence created to protect us
[Music]
very existence
we are this close to winning the war
the AI are developing a super weapon
retreat
they went
[Music]
did you locate the weapon yeah it's just
a kid
no
you gotta be a good person to go to
heaven
so we're the same we can't go to heaven
because you're not good
and I'm not a person
you're gonna do other things
she looks like a little girl now but
she's growing
Whoever has that kid wins the war
[Applause]
what do you want sweetie are robots to
be free
we don't have that in the fridge how
about ice cream
thank you
foreign
moved in here
it wasn't as warm as we hoped
okay I'm gonna light a vanilla candle
and it's going to be a game changer
and after midnight the house comes alive
this place is haunted
we need your help
it's time to assemble the Dream Team
we find someone who can communicate with
these ghosts
people used to eat here
I told you she's good oh it's a dining
room I found a professor who else wanted
mansions
I've been dying to go to this place for
years
mystery lurks around every corner
[Music]
I can show you what happened but it will
cost you
three dollars
who said that
you're not that scary you're really not
well you're pretty terrifying can you
turn around just while I finish this up
thank you
guys is anybody else seeing this yeah
I'm seeing it
hold on
solve this mystery
cure for eternity
you're all in for a treat
[Music]
so
cute I've found something
I've looked at it from Every Which Way I
Am the smartest person I ever met and I
can't figure it out so I came to the
second you are up to something my friend
I've seen a million these so-called
psychics each one of fake
I do not believe in psychics come with
me to a seance spot the con I can't
detective you are here to discredit me
but I can talk to the Dead
give all I have to hear
[Music]
we are here listening
um
what is happening
[Applause]
[Music]
the contraup is here somebody is dead no
one shall leave this place until I know
who did it a ghost killed her
yeah
there must be our rational answer for
all of this just admit that you are up
against something bigger than you no
[Music]
you were saying
something in this house tried to kill me
don't look at me like I'm suspect we're
old friends
every mother is somebody's old friend
no one shall leave until I find if the
living have been killed by the Dead
you have been hiding here all this time
who are you talking to
[Music]
thank you
sir I don't understand that's glaringly
apparent I can't fail this class oh
don't sell yourself short Mr coats I
truly believe that you can
every year at Barton Academy students
faculty and staff depart the campus for
a two-week winter break but there are
always an unfortunate few who have
nowhere to go for the holidays they're
known as the holdovers Mr Hannah hello
Mary I heard you guys stuck with
babysitting duty this year how'd you
manage that you know it used to be a
student right that's why he knows how to
inflict maximum pain on them
I thought all the Nazis were hiding in
Argentina stifled Telly
you just earned yourself a detention sir
being here with you he's already one big
attention son of a that's another
detention do you think I want to be
babysitting you no I was praying your
mother would pick up the phone or your
father would arrive in a helicopter or a
flying saucer father's dead
you don't tell a boy that's been left
behind at Christmas that nobody wants
him what's wrong with you there's nobody
here okay you stay out of my way and
I'll stay out of yours let me sleep
most of the kids dislike you pretty much
hate you teachers too you know that
right I find the world all day bitter
and complicated place and it seems to
feel the same way about me I think you
and I have this in common
I don't think I've ever had a real
family Christmas like this before
thank you Mary you're welcome history is
not simply the study of the past it is
an explanation of the present see when
you say it that way and throw in some
pornography it's a lot easier to
understand
I'd like to propose a toast to my two
unlikely companions
are you trying to lift down my shirt
yes you're gonna get me fired this is
your Rubicon do not cross
the holdovers
[Music]
I have been having it this stranger
streams
Rachel dreams are not reliable
analytical material that's so 20th
century
um
hi Rachel we're delighted to let you
know that we've had movement on our wait
list
we got a spot at the womb Center
but I haven't told Elvie yet oh why
why he wants a natural child
oh hold on you put us on a wait list to
have a baby in a name even though it's
not an egg it's it's an egg
women are reluctant to have children
because it's not made convenient we want
them to pursue their careers and dreams
we can't live in the past I want to have
a child with you I still really yeah
I'm sure you're all very excited parents
are raving about it it is the ultra
solution
my nephew was born at the boom Center
but he doesn't dream I wouldn't worry
about it
[Music]
I can't do it with a pot in here what
are you talking about it can't see us
I feel Alvey is able to bond with a
child but I'm not
maybe I'm just not ready to be a mother
you know no one's a mother just like
that you become one
we are considering having a home birth
I'm sorry it's not possible I won't
raise this child without nature
congratulations it's so exciting isn't
it
I noticed a change in productivity you
do have a baby at the womb center right
why
[Music]
things are evolving your family Dynamics
are about to undergo treatment changes
how can we make sure our baby's not
bored in utero oh yeah we don't want any
board babies
I think that we ought to change our
Town's slogan a great place to call home
is confusing I suggest a great place to
refer to as home we need a crosswalk on
Trent Avenue between Frost and Allegheny
and also
[Music]
oh my oh UFO has crashed my backyard has
taken out my azaleas and destroyed my
bird bath
when you talk like that it makes them
all take us less seriously
the UFO
what is that you remember the spaceship
this is the little man who came out of
it he's got to be a secret don't tell
anybody
she shouldn't know we gotta trust her
there's nothing else we can do you can
kill her kill me
I'll kill you that's what I'll do
it he's more of a Gary your dad was in
here earlier he said he was buying
apples for an alien like an illegal
alien thank you for the picture he hands
them to me all the time maybe he's
trying to tell you something dad come on
I'm worried what you have said has not
been normal I'm okay how can you say
that when you're buying apples for an
alien
[Music]
searching for
the summit we waste is a moment they can
discover him you've seen the movies you
know what happens to these guys when
they fall to occur
[Music]
I mean quite a bit to us
it's about Dad buying apples for an
alien
they're coming
last four hanging out together we get
along pretty well we're so thankful for
you
[Music]
what the
um
Alice engaging with trolls is like the
worst possible use of your energy
[Music]
since you joined BuzzFeed your art got
super lame and you die in a fire
don't judge me or sometimes you gotta
troll the trolls
[Music]
ha
ha ha
[Music]
foreign
belongs to you really think a weird
account is haunting your apartment
here David he was only 10 and his mother
went insane
because you're a son
coma
Dr Landers
[Music]
oh my God
what does he want ask him yourself
[Music]
this is the story of Alejandro he
immigrated to the most competitive place
on Earth to become a world famous Roy
designer I'm actually from El Salvador
purposes yes and those nuns they killed
in the ATC right
you think this lady can sponsor you I
mean we'll see
you
need cash hi can I ask you a question
about your hair oh wait I mean this
sucks so much for you I need to get paid
maybe freelance oh my God leave
you seem so convinced this is gonna work
out
solution
and remember it's everything or
everything
[Music]
according to my calculations that is not
the amount I should have in my account
what balance were you expecting zero
would be great just just get me to zero
I sent you the royal wedding the simple
instructions
don't cause an international incident
how's it going
you've done some pretty stupid things in
your day but this thanks the cake
[Music]
Henry shoved me an urge I currently
saved
what I need is some good old-fashioned
damaged control
the White House and the palace are going
to release a joint statement
you've got to be choking you can hate
Prince Henry all you want Mandy is
bigger than yours I want you to know
that they're wearing lifts no not too
sweetheart you better act like the
Sunshine's out of his ass and you have a
vitamin D deficiency I think excellent
is what you might say to convince the
world that we're actually friends I love
hanging out with this guys
[Music]
you're expecting at my New Year's party
I do something wrong you don't wonder
who you'd be if you were an anonymous
person in the world I have no idea what
you're talking about
[Music]
your majesty it's your Royal Highness
dear Alex I miss you
good morning we are in a hotel crawling
with reporters if anyone sees you leave
this hotel I will brexit your head from
your body your Royal Highness
figure out if you feel forever about him
do you love him what difference for the
man if I did
Prince Henry belongs to Britain we can
figure out a way to love each other on
our own terms it's like there's a robot
test to my chest and it keeps pulling me
towards you
hopefully we'll get through tonight
without any more scandals
the night is young Ma
thank you
I always like disguises
it's what you do when you don't really
know who you are right
dress up you make up a pass to forget
your own
I love dogs huh
more than you love your own family
I do
did you know anyone else
somebody that can show you some
attention or affection your child takes
affection where you can get it
clear my babies
as far as I can tell they only have one
flaw
you trust humans
you see while the real world constantly
rejected me you're the Devil
he's sending it back to hell
[Music]
oh
my God
you're insane
thank you
sometimes I like to just focus on your
voice and your words without that
distracting face of yours yeah all right
I have a boyfriend
uh wow that's cool you can't stop
smiling I've never met anyone like him
do I know him
no
don't answer that hi Eric who are you
who is that
honey we met online you met on the
internet yeah
[Music]
meet someday
you are even prettier in person
how old is this guy not College mid 20s
mid 20s okay you should be careful you
don't really know this guy
and I'm too late he wants to meet you
and I want you to meet him
get the hell out of my house Mom get out
now I know that this is hard for you
but we felt like this was the right
thing to do
hang it out in the open
whatever you think you have with Anna
it's over I didn't think she'd go as
crazy as she did I never want to see
that man again
you think this is over this whole messed
up thing that you're doing here I don't
want you to get hurt
foreign
[Music]
you don't know what it's like
losing your hair you might as well be
dead
[Music]
ah did I even know it's murder someone
Scout him
but you're right
all right
no
he was dead
they follow me dead people all I wanna
do is cut hair
and they keep dropping
how do you tell someone
they don't care about perms
[Music]
he's fixing this one smarter some kind
of gangster fixing the show of murder
and the rivals
I might take that break now yeah
this is the crowns
that you never take off
[Music]
another glorious morning it's a good
surfing day just put on your sunscreen
and head off isn't it good to be alive
he's easily influenced an angel with
their own sword
mate I'm in deep trouble one favor I
haven't got 100 Grand you're causing me
grief with my girl
so you're saying you're going to knock
off this shipment to repay your debts if
I support you on this one you leave me
alone
you okay
when I come back I'm gonna take you
somewhere special
let's all raise a toaster I'd like to
thank everyone for coming to my home
tonight
you better find my drugs
someone break into your place I can't do
this they want their drugs and they're
coming for you they come for me I'm
giving them you Marshon
committed to this road trip
or something that belongs to me
what do you want I'm looking for someone
it could be dangerous
[Music]
thank you